why do I fix everything I touch so I was
all set to have a video go up today
about the new x-men and Marvel related
movies that Fox said they're working on
and then a trailer drop so that means
that gets bumped to tomorrow and today I
talked about the first proper trailer
for wreck-it Ralph - Ralph breaks the
Internet so uh you may have guessed from
the outfit I'm a fairly big fan of
wreck-it Ralph actually I go far as to
say I love wrecker Alf it's one of my
favorite Disney movies of the last few
years I like it almost as much as I like
Zootopia I like it a little bit more
than frozen if I'm being honest I like
it a lot it's fun it's funny it's
touching their parts of it I find
incredibly moving I love it and so this
trailer has come out this is our first
good proper look at the thing and and
you know coming in as someone who loves
these characters I saw this trailer and
I hate everything so let me be failed
even coming into this I was already
skeptical because I tend to be skeptical
of any film that is a sequel to a movie
that not only didn't have a story that
necessitated a sequel but also had
characters complete their arcs already
that's I think where a lot of sequels
fall down it's different when you're
dealing with something like an action
franchise where you can just set them in
a different setting and just let the
action flow again if it's actually truly
about the characters much more than the
set pieces or anything else if they've
completed a character arc by the time
the movies done it's hard to pick up
again after that and one of two things
usually happens either they find a
reason to reset the character back to
how they were pre completing their art
before and you just see a retread of the
exact same thing again or they
manufacture something that is that is
going to
either feel like a retread of their
previous art or feels like a completely
manufactured reason for them to have a
new arc that doesn't feel like an actual
progression of what came before this is
why the latter Shrek movies are so
painful because over the course of those
first two he had a complete journey from
the grumpy place he started out to being
a family man and being happy with that
you know having being married and and
having all of that and then first Shrek
three and four they have to set him back
to being grumpy ogre again even though
the entire point of the previous movies
was him not needing to be that any more
it it's why finding Dory is one of the
very few kind these kinds of sequels
that has worked because rather than
focus on those two main on those two
main characters being Marlin a Nemo
again the ones who went through arcs
where they had to learn and adjust their
own behavior in their own lives instead
it focused on a side character who was a
lot of fun but didn't really have an arc
in the film focus on her and the other
ones be the side thing and I think that
would have been the smarter thing to do
with Rekha Ralph too would have been to
have it focus on somebody else whether
it's vanellope whether it's Felix
whether it's Calhoun whether it's a new
character but putting Ralph front and
center and putting his name in the title
Ralph breaks the Internet I think it's
hard to argue that it's not going to be
him front and center so I was already
nervous going in for that reason alone
because he completed his art and nothing
about the previous one necessitated a
follow-up but even with that in mind I
love these characters I love this world
I would be happy to see more of it if
it's done well but like I said I really
hate this and before anybody leaps down
on me going
don't judge a movie by the trailer first
of all I'm not judging the movie I'm
judging the trailer I'm judging the
trailer by itself everything I talk
about from this point forward it's gonna
be me talking about what is in the
trailer I'm not talking about the rest
of the movie I haven't seen the rest of
the movie but I'm gonna talk
about what's in this trailer I'm gonna
judge the hell out of it and it's my
right to because you know why trailers
exist they exist to be judged that is
why they are here because companies
Disney in this case put out trailers so
you can judge them they hope you will
judge that you want to see the movie
that's not my judgment based off this
but it exists to be judged so don't tell
me that I should not be judging a
trailer because yes I should it's why it
exists so at home coming in right off
the bat we get the setup of the arcade
being hooked up to the Internet I'm like
okay not sure where that goes and then
there goes of NLP and Ralph's off to the
internet and then we start getting papa
bad jokes and ebay jokes and even if I I
get really generous and say that the and
don't make the assumption that these are
already dated now if not by the time the
movie comes out even if that isn't the
case this is gonna age poorly all these
references a big part of what was smart
about the previous film was that it was
deliberately dealing with retro stuff
that in fact is still around to various
degrees not necessarily actual you know
coin-op arcades but old-school games
still exists and still have fan bases
and are still being discovered by
younger gamers so we know these are
things that have endured and really the
only bit of touching on modern gaming
that that first movie did was with
hero's duty but that was not like a
primary focus it was basically touching
on Wow having games changed a lot but
then we move on because that's not what
it's about it's about Ralph
so lingering as this does as the trailer
does because I'd like to say the movie
may not but the movie has Internet in
the title it's hard for me to imagine
that it won't but moving on from that
you know it's it's just lingering on
these and these Joe
our first of all I didn't think they
were funny second of all even if I did
think they were funny they're gonna like
I said they're gonna age really badly
you know what it's gonna feel like it's
gonna feel like the emoji movie with all
of its dance dance revelution and candy
crush references which were already like
oh that thing from like a year ago by
the time that movie came out and I can't
imagine it's not gonna be a very similar
situation here they probably know enough
to not reference specific apps etc by
name unless they are ones like eBay that
have stood the test of time and aren't
liable to already be a flash in the pan
that's over by the time the movie gets
to theaters but it doesn't matter
because this will be referencing types
of things that are flash-in-the-pan kind
of things so we've got all that none of
this is clicking for me none of this is
making me smile
even being with these characters who I
love and then we get to the joke with
the bunny and the cat and the little kid
game and and I have a young kid so I'm
familiar with these types of games
pancake milkshake pancake my get it and
this is a setup that should work
because unlike the general internet
jokes this is a game this is Ralph's
bread and butter Ralph's knows games he
knows how games are so there's something
to be milked out of how games have
changed in now this is the kind of game
that didn't exist until a few years ago
for a very young kid very highly
simplistic game and you haven't even got
to get into and be like oh I see the Sun
up there someone okay this is it a bad
moment it's much more organic again
putting him in a game of some form feels
better feels appropriate but then the
the degree that they take the joke too
and you can call me a stick-in-the-mud
you can call me a buzzkill you can call
me a party pooper I don't find
traumatizing children to be funny I
never have long before I have my own kid
and
found that kind of stuff funny so the
one set up and gag that I was kind of
like okay maybe then overstepped and I
hate it because and and before you talk
this up to me being too sensitive you
could have the joke without traumatizing
a child all you would have had to have
done was have this kid staring at this
thing going something's wrong with my
game and hand it to any older member of
her family we saw like a mother's
driving maybe she hands it to her father
or you know a nod toward some other
adults in the front seat something's
wrong with my game an older sibling even
sitting next door somebody 10 or up
somebody who might think that what's
going on is weird but could cope with
what they're about to see because you
know we don't see it but the gag is that
the bunny has exploded and you could
have a reaction from an adult from an
older kid being you know sort of blah or
or from an adult being um why don't we
try a different game or at some of that
you could even have them give us a
freakout reaction and it'd be okay
because it would just be shocked it
wouldn't be the result of them being
traumatized from having an emotional
connection to this game and this bunny
which I kid that young would and I know
I'm getting overly weirdly hung up on
this I accept that but no I hate that
it's not okay it's not funny
childhood trauma like that needless
gratuitous childhood trauma is not funny
not when the trauma itself is what we
are meant to be laughing at it's
possible to make a joke about anything
but when the joke is literally just ha
traumatize child there it is not funny
so I hate this trailer by I I do have to
use the word hate I can't say just like
I can't say disappointed by I hey this
trailer but like I said I will judge the
ever-loving heck out of this trailer I'm
not going to judge the movie by it
because I haven't seen the movie so
let's put on our silver lining rose
tinted glasses and say it is distinctly
possible that there is more going on
here than what I'm seeing because I mean
what we get in this is we get set up but
no plot we don't know what the plot of
the thing is at all we only know what
the new set up is the new situation is
and some of the new environments are so
there's plenty of room for the actual
plot whatever it may be to pick up the
slack I'm still skeptical about that
because like I said Ralph's completed
his arc and if he's front and center on
this again I don't know how they're
gonna do something other than Ralph's
screwed something out but now has to fix
it I mean that's kind of what the first
one was so not only would that feel like
a retread but the thing about the first
one is not only did he have to fix
something it was about his personal
journey was about his acceptance of his
role as a as the villain of the game but
that doesn't make him a bad person and
it was about a personal journey in
conjunction with the fact that he had to
fix something that he broke that
personal journey is now complete so
having him having to fix something that
he broke whether it's the weather even
if it's something much bigger like the
Internet that's not gonna have the same
resonance as it did last time it can't
and and even if you try to make it by
like I've said before and resetting him
so that he needs to go through this arc
again it can't ring is true the second
time the other example that I tend to
think of in my head is Cloudy with a
Chance of Meatballs 2 which is a
visually inventive film and I love the
foodimals but everything aside from them
I really really doesn't work for me and
I think the reason it doesn't is what
was great about the first credit of the
Chance of Meatballs movie was that
pretty much every single character
except the mayor who was almost a
villain has an arc and completes it and
has a journey and has something that
they learn and makes them change and so
when you reassemble all these characters
in the sequel there's nothing to do with
them but just plunk them down on a new
situation so instead they invent a new
sort of having you know the main
character in that
have to overcome this thing that all of
a sudden he has this issue it's a bit
like how in the in the second and third
Back to the Future movies out of nowhere
Marty can't handle being called chicken
which never came up in the first movie
they had to had to imprint something for
him to grow over because he was he was
fine at the end of the of the previous
film that's the same thing that is
potentially could happen here but look
like I said this is a few scant moments
and I even went back and looked at the
initial trailer for the first
wreckit-ralph and thought did the
trailer for the first one would that
have left me cold as well and in some
ways it did because I actually record
Ralph I didn't rush out himself and see
in the theater
I waited for a home video for to see
that movie but that that first trailer
for that movie gave us a sense of the
character and a sense of his conflict
because even in that very first trailer
you know he's saying I don't want to be
the bad guy anymore
so it immediately clued you into where
the journey is this
I'm just getting gags and if they don't
hit and they didn't for me then there's
nothing I'm not getting a sense of
anybody needing anything as a character
from this and that that worries me there
is this is a two minute something
trailer there's plenty of room for there
to be plenty of things that actually
make this film work or even have it be
great but nothing that they show me in
this trailer works for me
and I have no idea if this is a common
reaction that I'm having to this herbes
completely you know way off to the side
because I watch the trailer I didn't
even make a mental note of what the up
vote down vote ratio was I am around
other people's reactions I don't know if
I am vocalizing what other people feel
or if I am completely an anomalous in
all this I'm sure folks will tell me
either way in any case first trailer for
wreck-it Ralph to
what do you think about it how would you
fix it
whoever your thoughts are drop something
down in the comments let's talk about it
there's all the stuff to do you know
light subscribe patreon buy t-shirt
podcasts Twitter
bleurgh links for everything is down in
the description so until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]